for the royals lefty mike miner their
veteran will be on the hill today
and they need a big start from mike the
boston red sox arroyo swings and pops it
up on the infield
and the sun is a factor in comes
gutierrez he can't find it and the ball
drops
well the first thing you you look for
when when a player has a hard time with
the sun
is where are your sunglasses okay that's
the first question
second question is how do you explain
that to mike miner when the next guy
hits a two-run homer good at numbers and
the home run potential's there but
double play is as well
one
and
done
beautiful thing roll them over on a
sunday afternoon
nathan nevaldi will be the pitcher for
boston he's pitched very well of late
7-3 overall as his record in 14 starts
averaging 97 miles an hour on that
fastball and quit hits one right back to
the mountain
one out
it's that one sharply knocking it down
is arroyo and he'll throw him out one
two three go the royals miner never
rattles
he walks renfro on four pitches and now
must face [ __ ] hernandez who had a very
good game yesterday kiki had a big day
at the plate yesterday walked twice
singled and scored two runs in the
seventh hole again
get out of here that's deep left field
way back it goes and kiki crushes one
goodness gracious his sixth of the
season so a two down a walk and a blast
and the red sox have the lead in kansas
city wow 424 feet that's a long way for
[ __ ] hernandez
line sharply left center field
now he's going for two and he makes it
they got him apparently they got him as
he came in standing up
they're staying safe well you know
they've asked monday to play
smart and that's a split finger that
stayed up look at that he waited and
went the other way how about that so
playing smart now he wasn't sure whether
to go or not
and he was able to sneak in there and
they never touched him apparently weight
on him trying to go to right field
and he does for a base hit
monday turns third and now they're going
to hold him
[Applause]
they send the runner there's a tapper
back to the mound they hold the runner
only play will be first base but two out
[Applause]
to right field but
it's bobbled and the royals will score a
run on the bobble by dalbeck
michael a taylor how about some english
on that ball putting a little bit of
spin on there made it extremely
difficult for dolbach they send taylor
again but a swing and a miss by lopez
and that will do it but the royals get a
run
negotiate with the fan yeah i'm curious
if you got the ball i've not heard oh
that one might get out did pretty well
merrifield again back to the wall
can't get it
they had a real tough time with that one
jd rounding on his way into third
and that's a triple for jd martinez it
looked playable
by mary field but he didn't see it yeah
i agree i think two things he took a bad
route at it
after it and then when he when he looked
up he couldn't see it the count two
balls two strikes
monday
got him
with mayor field to right field
he stays hot his fourth hit of this
series
[Applause]
oh it's off of vivaldi now the only
players at first base
so he does with a liner to center field
win around third coming home here's the
throw
it's well off line and salvy has tied
the game
boy that's exactly what you do he made
an adjustment from that first big swing
to the right side and it eats up the
second baseman arroyo
perez around second to third monday will
make it to second
and the ball got tied up
he walked him
how about that jarrod dyson comes
through and comes perez and comes
modesty
the royals take the lead
and it took off from there
he punches that one over the leap and
gutierrez down the line
dyson over to dig it out
kiki romping into second base so he's
putting together a really nice day with
a bad a home run and now double
that's a basin into left field
tk will stop at third base throw coming
back in another hit for bobby d and he
is two for two
slow roll right side easy play for lopez
good job by miner he gets the shutdown
inning we head to the bottom of the
fourth royals four red sox two
there's a looper for a base hit way to
go nikki
bob
now
another good turn over there at first
base
and lopez went on the delayed steal and
the ball goes into center field
so lopez now seven four seven stealing
bases leads the team with four home runs
this month
and he knocks that one sharply to left
field for a hit
another very good hitter there's short
stop right hand batter and he'll swing
and light it into right center that's a
hit widover to play it rounding second
going to third is arroyo
and suddenly the red sox have him at the
corners with two down
from the stretch kicks and deals and a
swing and a miss he strikes out
endeavors to end the fifth inning and
three in the third to take the lead the
pitch swing
and a little popper into shallow center
in comes the center fielder out goes the
second baseman neither can make the
catch and hunter dozier has a bloop
double and arroyo is hurt so uh
standing ovation to the training staff
for both the red sox and royals
pulled to the right side
knocked down and lopez is going to have
himself another hit
he want to walk he'd be a mailman he
wants to hit like whit
hits that one well dave to left that's
the way back it's a goner for
whitmerfield
a little insurance there making it six
to two as the royals
still batting here in the bottom of the
sixth inning underside and some carry to
go with it
and now a shot to right field by santana
salve taps one past the mound charging
is denver's quick toss safe
are you kidding me a three walk game for
kelvin gutierrez i'll be the first in
his career doing that bases are loaded
for dozier
up the middle
they've got nowhere to go and a run
scores making it seven to two royals
[Applause]
left center field taylor won't be able
to reach this one he'll fire it into
first base and hold verdugo to a single
hit sharply into left field
all right watch for mike miner to get a
major ovation here
better believe it
mike miner was major
happy father's day
struck him out on three pitches
way to pick up mike miner
on the afternoon is grounded out to
short to second and he has whiffed
[Music]
stings this one is center field
out of here indeed
wow way back there over the 410 he did
not wait around
his 18th home run of the season the red
sox on the board for the first time
since the second inning
and then he
flares one into left field for a hit on
a 2-2 count
all four
[Applause]
ball four and the bases are loaded
oh beauty alberto
lopez
done
just what zimmer needed
popped him up this should do it
alberto wants it
makes the catch and the royals
win their first series from boston since
july 2017.
[Applause]